Sunny Hosten over at the view do we have
a warning for the good people Sunny
Hostin over at the view is very very
concerned she still thinks that we're in
1940s America and watch this
that the lived experience of a white kid
in Appalachia or perhaps on a potato
farm in Idaho or in Brooklyn it's
different in this country for a black
student whether that black student be
wealthy or not because this country was
founded on slavery this is such epic
what an embarrassment ABC has done with
the view this country was founded on
slavery the country was not founded on
slavery as a matter of fact we fought a
civil war to end slavery not too long
after our Inception there were countries
that existed for hundreds and hundreds
of years before us that continued the
practice of slavery long after we got
rid of it okay but putting that aside so
that's just a lie and she's just an
idiot what she's trying to tell you
let's go what she's trying to tell you
is that Carlton had it worse than those
poor kids little little buckwheat over
there he was hanging out with the white
kids nobody was racist against buckwheat
look they they just it's just pure
nonsense she's trying to convince you
she's trying it's so sad actually that's
what she's doing it's so sad if you're a
15 year old black kid and you heard that
from Sunny Hosten and you live in Malibu
right you're surfing during the day with
your friends and you're being told that
you are somehow more oppressed in this
state that was that was founded on
oppressing your ancestors then the kid
who's growing up in rural Kentucky with
next to nothing and we're supposed to
believe this is this is real and honest
foreign
[Music]